[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista hoy nos
acompaña yamila Ribeiro filósofa
escritora y periodista brasileña y
autora de libros como pequeño manual
Andrés antirracista o quién tiene miedo
de ser en negro yamila también es
profesora en la universidad pontificia
de Sao Paulo y es colaboradora del medio
de comunicación apoya di Sao Paulo
bienvenidas yamila Muchas gracias
yamilas yamila si usted tuviera que
escoger entre uno de sus libros como el
más importante cuál sería Y por qué Y
por qué
es difícil escoger el primer libro que
se tradujo al español fue lugares de
habla lugares de enunciación después
quién tiene miedo del feminismo negro y
ahora pequeño manual anti racista me
parece difícil escoger Cuál es el más
importante pero creo que pequeño manual
en Brasil es un messeller entonces
seguramente escogería este porque creo
que es un libro que vendió más de
500.000 copias en Brasil está presente
en varias escuelas y universidades y
espero que ahora aquí en América Latina
también consiga difundirse desde este
ámbito más educativo
y yamila
cuál fue el momento en el que te diste
cuenta de que los negros sufren o
presión en Brasil
desde mi infancia en la familia en la
que crecí mi padre era activista
Entonces desde bien pronto estas
conversaciones estuvieron presentes en
mi casa mi padre me llevaba a
asociaciones presentaba libros Entonces
fui consciente desde muy temprano mis
hermanos y yo estuvimos muy formados por
los movimientos sociales para entender
Cómo funciona el racismo en Brasil pero
también para posicionarnos en contra de
él desde la infancia y después fue un
camino natural fui trabajando en
organizaciones del movimiento negro en
organizaciones feministas negras hasta
llegar a hacer todo el camino que hice
pero es algo que me viene de casa eso
desde luego
dónde crees que está el límite para que
las personas blancas se impliquen en la
lucha anti racista crees que están
ocupando este espacio que pertenece a
los negros negros
en el pequeño manual tengo un capítulo
en el que hablo de la importancia de que
las personas blancas se posicionen en
contra del racismo porque el racismo es
un problema de la sociedad no solo de
las personas negras o de las personas
indígenas Entonces es importante que las
personas blancas estudien sobre el tema
se conciencian se posicionen en contra
de eso ya sea estudiando creando
oportunidades o abriendo la mente de
otras personas blancas yo creo que
tienen un papel fundamental porque no es
un problema solo de los negros es de
toda la sociedad
olfato de ser en negro y olfato el hecho
de ser negro y ser pobre están muy
relacionados en Brasil y es aún peor en
el caso de las mujeres negras crees que
la lucha anti racista y feminista tienen
relación con la lucha de clases
sin ninguna duda nosotras como
feministas negras creemos que esas
luchas son inseparables porque la mujer
negra por ejemplo es la base de la
pirámide social en Brasil justo porque
tiene la triple opresión de raza clase y
género entonces creemos que no podemos
discutir sobre la clase en Brasil sin
hablar de la cuestión racial en un país
que tuvo 400 años de esclavitud entonces
en Brasil las personas negras son pobres
porque son negras porque su mano de obra
fue explotada históricamente y después
no hubo ningún tipo de reparación
entonces esa discusión es fundamental y
es necesario que se haga de forma
conjunta las luchas no pueden estar
separadas si yo Lucho contra el machismo
Pero no entiendo también que es una
estructura estoy alimentando la misma
estructura la lucha feminista negra es
anti racista anticapitalista y
antisaxista
Háblame sobre la situación de las
mujeres en Brasil y qué mujer es una
referente para ti
[Música]
violento
países
[Música]
sexuales por desgracia Brasil es un país
muy violento para las mujeres es el
quinto país con más asesinatos de
mujeres en todo el mundo también tiene
un índice muy grande de violencia sexual
contra las mujeres y niñas creo que ese
debate es fundamental para la sociedad
brasileña porque aún faltan políticas
públicas para poder hacer frente a ese
problema en Brasil también hay un número
altísimo de tráfico de niñas y mujeres y
de explotación sexual y ese debate es
fundamental no es un debate separado
como muchas personas piensan a veces a
No eso es cuestión de las mujeres pero
las mujeres forman parte de la sociedad
están afectadas por la opresión de clase
y necesitamos entender que dentro de la
clase trabajadora existen hombres
trabajadores y mujeres trabajadoras las
mujeres normalmente van a trabajar fuera
y dentro de casa con el cuidado de Los
hijos es necesario que la gente piense
en esas mujeres brasileñas de una manera
que reconozca todos esos problemas
desgraciadamente las mujeres negras son
las más vulnerables en Brasil somos el
mayor grupo demográfico en Brasil
representamos el 28% de la población y
es imprescindible y esperamos tener
políticas públicas diferentes para
enfrentar la violencia doméstica y la
violencia sexual por otro lado es
importante hablar también de la
importancia de los movimientos
feministas en Brasil en nuestra historia
Contamos con mujeres que fueron
importantes en la lucha de los derechos
de las mujeres y yo vengo de esa
generación trabaje con mujeres de
generaciones pasadas que fueron
fundamentales para mi formación
[Música]
y yo creo que las generaciones más
jóvenes y entrenadas en las redes
sociales necesitan conocer el trabajo de
las mujeres que pavimentaron su camino y
sus historias Porque nada nos cayó del
cielo fue el resultado de mucha lucha de
mucho trabajo y esas mujeres fueron
fundamentales para mí en Brasil como él
ya González Luisa bairos fueron teóricas
activistas y que trabajaron en los
gobiernos pensando en políticas públicas
por eso suelo decir que esas mujeres me
salvaron con ellas empecé a no sentirme
sola cuando leí a Tony Morrison que es
mi escritora favorita con 19 años cambió
mi vida entonces tengo referencias en
varios ámbitos en la literatura en el
activismo en la política y eso para mí
fue fundamental para convertirme en la
mujer que soy hoy pero también
entendiendo mi responsabilidad como
mujer de mi generación que necesita
continuar con el camino que labraron las
que nos precedieron responsabilidad
y crees que la situación de las mujeres
va a mejorar con el gobierno de Lula con
el PT
más esperemos que sí
volvimos a tener un Ministerio de las
mujeres que se preocupa de verdad por el
bienestar de las mujeres porque con la
administración anterior no fue así Hay
un plan para enfrentar la violencia
contra las mujeres pasamos cuatro años
tenebrosos en Brasil en los que no había
preocupación sobre el tema de las
mujeres ahora Esperamos que con el
Ministerio de las mujeres podamos
avanzar ampliar en las redes de combate
contra las violencias y de algunas que
ya conseguimos poner el foco como la
despenalización del aborto poder seguir
El ejemplo de los países de Sudamérica
que han despenalizado el aborto como
Argentina o México y en Brasil
infelizmente este es aún un debate muy
religioso aunque seamos un estado laico
con este gobierno al menos tenemos la
posibilidad de un diálogo de abertura y
Esperamos que nuestra ministra siga con
Sábes consiga concretar políticas
importantes en ese área
y las últimas de la historia en las
últimas elecciones de Brasil me quedé
impactada porque de los principales
candidatos ninguno era negro Cuál es la
situación de la lucha antirracista en
Brasil actualmente piensas que los
negros tienen la suficiente
representación en los espacios
brasileños en el país pasos
no infelizmente la representación Aún es
muy insuficiente Hay pocas personas
negras en el congreso nacional o en el
senado en comparación con la cantidad de
población negra representamos el 54% de
la población en Brasil Somos la mayoría
pero infelizmente aún somos La minoría
de los espacios institucionales
sistemas y la importancia
como es un área que tiene que ser muy
discutida Incluso en los medios
progresistas hay una resistencia para
estos temas y la importancia en pensar
No solo Quienes son los beneficiarios de
las políticas públicas sino en Quién las
piensan y las generan por lo que esas
dinámicas también afectan mucho a la
cuestión económica porque las personas
negras no tienen un fortalecimiento
económico para poder hacer campañas y
estar en los espacios hubo un cambio muy
importante en las últimas elecciones el
Tribunal Superior electoral estableció
una cuota paritaria de raza en los
partidos entonces una cantidad de
asientos deben ser destinados a los
negros eso es reciente en Brasil y
Esperamos que esa medida impacte
positivamente en el aumento de
candidatos negros con el paso de los
años
un bloqueo de raza y de clase verdad
exactamente
y la cadena bbc te clasificó entre las
100 mujeres más influyentes del mundo
llegaste a pensar o imaginaste alguna
vez que llegarías tan lejos
para mí fue una sorpresa en 2019 cuando
recibí Este título de la bbc pero me
hizo muy feliz por ser una mujer negra
brasileña porque la gente tiene una
visión muy estereotipada de Brasil
siempre nos suelen analizar bajo una
perspectiva negativa o de objetivación
de las mujeres las personas no conocen
el Brasil real no saben que hay muchas
luchas en Brasil muchos intelectuales
importantes entonces me hace muy feliz
ser una mujer negra brasileña
representando Brasil de una forma que
rompe con esos estereotipos que tienen
el resto del mundo sobre el país
[Música]
y para ti Cuál es el objetivo de tu
trabajo en general
pues diría que yo diría que es formación
de consciencia pienso que la gente que
trabaja con esta cuestión editorial
Porque además de ser escritora yo tengo
una editorial con la que publico el
trabajo de otros autores sobre todo
mujeres de Brasil Entonces yo creo mucho
en el cambio de la mentalidad a través
de la educación y por eso diría que mi
trabajo es fundamentalmente un trabajo
de transformación mediante la educación
y profesional para cerrar yamila Si te
tuvieras que autodefinir con unas
palabras cómo lo harías palabras
difícil pero a mí me gusta decir que soy
una trabajadora de las palabras una
trabajadora de la educación porque creo
que a veces cuando ganas un poco de
visibilidad las personas creen que
cambias por completo pero yo sigo
trabajando para mí eso no ha cambiado
Sigo creyendo lo mismo sigo publicando
autores tengo un instituto en Sao Paulo
ahora que acaba de cumplir un año Desde
allí apoyamos a mujeres sobre la
violencia doméstica tenemos talleres
educacionales entonces me definiría como
un activista pero sobre todo como una
trabajadora de las palabras que cree la
transformación
y tienes esperanza en Brasil a piensas
que va a mejorar siempre tengo esperanza
soy una optimista realista pero siempre
tengo esperanza creo que cuando la gente
pierde la esperanza deja de luchar y
creo que las generaciones anteriores
muchas veces no experimentaron los
cambios por los que lucharon pero yo sí
los experimenté así como las
generaciones futuras como la de mi hija
las van a experimentar Creo que nunca
debemos perder eso de vista Muchas
gracias yamila muchas gracias y a
ustedes Muchas gracias por acompañarnos
para más entrevistas como esta y más
información síganos en France 24 y
France 24.com